France could soon become the first country in the world
to enshrine the right to abortion in its constitution.
But why is the government doing this now?
Is the right to abortion under threat in France today?
Abortion has been legal in France since 1975,
thanks to the law carried by then health
Minister Simon Vee.
But this right is threatened
because the law isn't properly applied. In France,
abortion can be difficult to access.
For the past 20 years,
around 220,000 women have had abortions each year,
and one in three women has an abortion in her lifetime.
But access to abortion has declined.
In 2005, 653 healthcare facilities performed abortions,
but by 2018
this number fell to 511.
This is mostly due to a lack of funds
or because there aren't enough doctors
willing to perform the procedure. In France,
the legal time frame for an abortion is up to 14
weeks of pregnancy,
but in some medical deserts,
it's difficult to get all the appointments
needed within a few weeks.
So access to abortion is unequal
depending on where you live and your means.
This right is also threatened by certain
anti abortion groups
who lobby politicians
or misinform women about the procedure.
If you search online,
you'll come across fake abortion information sites
that try to discourage women from having an abortion,
which is illegal.
But the government's move to enshrine
the right to abortion in the constitution
is also supposed to respond to a more Political threat
the aim is to make abortion
much more difficult to prohibit or restrict
if anti abortion political parties gain power
like in Poland,
Hungary and the United States.
In France, this is not an immediate threat,
although there are still several steps to go.
No political group in parliament
is opposed to enshrining abortion in the constitution.
Today, some conservative and far right leaders
have criticized the constitutional reform
as a political operation
and useless,
saying that Mackle is importing an American debate
following the Supreme Court's
decision to eliminate the constitutional
right to abortion last year.